hey man well thank you for thank you for
doing the show that was awesome
I enjoyed it I've been watching bill for
years I didn't know I would ever be
sitting opposite him but that was that
was fun it was good it was good um
now this interested me you started as a
writer for Bob Hope here oh yes you did
some standup my uncle who lived out here
in LA knew Bob Hope and said hey man
you're pretty funny if you want I can
get him the material right and he gets a
stack apparently or he used to get a
stack yeah he loved his jokes
so yeah so it's all everyday and he
liked my stuff when he called me so yeah
now and and and your mom answered the
phone that's a true story
she actually answered the phone and he
said you know it's uh it's Tom there
this is Bob Hope and she said really
this is the Queen of England and she
hung up true story how big was the
mobile home well the house I originally
moved in as a better thousand square
feet that's a that's a pretty pretty big
mobile home well now it's a it's a
classic double-wide a double-wide is
like we have on the lot I know I know
the language that you know the
double-wide yeah I know the the
dimensions a double-wide is classically
between 22 and 24 feet wide that's
double singles 12 of course and then
they run between 50 and 60 feet long so
you ever get a little stir-crazy no no
that's cool
truthfully never yeah yeah the square
footage thing is is hilarious to me
because I've had both I've lived in
17,000 square foot three home compound
right and then you sit in the same room
all the time well you're you know every
party ends up in the kitchen true that's
true very true even in the 17,000 square
foot gargantuan but you know what it's
just so much harder to live there like
really when you look at it it has its
advantages too but it's so much harder
if you forget something for example Oh
where'd my wallet go yeah holy it like
you know yeah in a small square footage
place you remember when you own an
apartment it was just like that was
either there or it was there you know
it's just so much more maintenance
there's so much more to do and so much
more bills to write there's just and you
don't you don't need it because you live
in a very small footprint their number
one thing that makes people happy is
relationships strong relationships
so oftentimes we who might have a lot of
money don't need each other we separate
ourselves we get behind gates and then
we get really unhappy we don't know why
right when people don't have resources I
have enough to eat of course you know
because that creates happiness as well
but but the fact that we need each other
we have to live in community I my house
is close to yours we see each other
that creates really happy right outcomes
what the the big question that everyone
probably wants us to talk about what
kind of conditioner Bumble and Bumble oh
really I don't know Mike my cousins a
hairdresser and in Virginia he sends me
but man I need a lot of it how long have
you had a life I was a child of the 70s
how about you I I think I did it I was
looking at some footage of me from 1993
I think 93 I got it down then we're not
here and then kept it ever since
yeah I got to do something that's you
know I don't know I'm like I call myself
homeless Jesus that's so ahead what
other issues can we I don't know how we
do amongst a lot is staring at me as I
see CVS but if you're paranoid this is
not the room who sit in